Я - Сергій Зінченко, провідний інженер центру з ремонту і експлуатації лінії.
Працюю в компанії майже 9 років.
Я народився в Київській області.
Найбільше подобається в моїй роботі те, що ми працюємо для того, щоб у людей було світло.
Наша робота - це робота з підвищеною небезпекою, крім обстрілів,
цієї війни є ще напруга, у якої немає ні запаху, ні кольору, нічого.
І люди постійно дуже близько біля неї, і це небезпечно.
Коли ми почали працювати на початку квітня, коли росіяни відійшли, ніхто не знав,
що таке снаряд, ніхто ніколи його не бачив, ці гармати, танки.
Був приліт, була пошкоджена двоколова високовольтна лінія
і повністю було знеструмлено містечко біля міста Києва.
Згарище, все чорне, горить трансформаторне масло, пошкоджене обладнання… Страшно.
Ми почали свої роботи десь о десятій вечора, темрява.
Нам знадобилося часу чотири години, щоб відремонтувати.
Це мінімальна робота, яку треба було зробити, щоб заживити тих 53 тисячі споживачів.
Основна проблема - це передача енергії кінцевому споживачу.
Тобто ми виробляємо, в Україні виробляється електроенергія,
просто проблема її перерозподілити і доставити до кінцевого споживача.
Скільки будуть перебивати, пошкоджувати, ми будемо лагодити, лагодити і ще раз лагодити.
Треба терпіти. Ось ці погодинні відключення - це теж робота.
Там сидять живі люди, які працюють, які теж мають право на помилку.
Графіки є, і ми намагаємося їх дотримуватися.
Буває, у формі повертаюся додому і там люди: "О, добрий день, як у вас там справи,
як ви сьогодні відпрацювали?" Уже, так би мовити, люди бачать,
і видно це навіть у будинку, де я живу.
Хтось воює, хтось зуби лікує, хтось пологи приймає, а хтось ремонтує дроти,
лагодить трансформатори пошкоджені.
Я вважаю, що всі ми герої, ми робимо свою роботу.